good morning Hank it's Wednesday I'm in
a parking lot so I love pranks I love
pulling pranks I love writing about
pranks in fact one time I was in a
Hollywood pitch meeting and this is a
totally true story and a Hollywood
executive described my first novel
Looking for Alaska as prank Academy with
some sad bits Oh Hollywood I love you
but Hank the only problem with pranks is
that they're generally designed to hurt
or diminish or humiliate someone else
right for instance when I recently threw
you in a pool that was designed to hurt
you to make other people laugh I can't
speak for other people ank but seeing
that still makes me laugh so anyway my
friend Amy Krauss Rosenthal recently
called me with an amazing idea
positive pranking oh hello target I'm
gonna need all your Tootsie Pops so
Amy's idea is that you can use the
pranking ethos to decrease worldsuck and
to launch this positive pranking
campaign she reinvented dingdong
ditching by delivering actual hostess
ding-dongs to strangers throughout
Chicago there's a link to watch that
video in the doobly-doo and then amy
gave me the idea that I could TP
people's houses with Tootsie Pops so
first about all the Tootsie Pops at
Target and a diet dr. pepper because I
was thirsty then I went home typed up a
note which you can read in the
doobly-doo printed it out and then
signed all 60 copies of it J scribble
and then I set off to TP some people so
some mailboxes in my neighborhood have
recently been the victim of negative
pranking involving baseball bats so I
started off by tp'ing some of those
mailboxes then I went to subway these
are for you they're a gift just 50 pops
and cut out a 6-inch one week so
eventually I developed a system wherein
I combined
tp'ing with dingdong ditching Hank doing
it that way seriously got my heart rates
spiking I mean I was walking up there
thinking oh god I hope they don't open
the door and then I put down the TP and
then I ring the doorbell and then ditch
and every single time I ran away like
panic panic if these people find out
that I'm trying to give them 20 puffs
the consequences will never be the same
then I got the idea to TP the garden at
my friend Chris and Marina's house then
I taped a note to their Bush so they'd
know they'd been positively pranked then
I went back to mail boxing for a while
until finally I discovered this lonely
and desolate island in this subdivision
and thought you know someone should TP
that Island
so I think that's the story of my first
go at being a positive prankster I now
turn this idea over to you and
nerdfighteria let's work together in
comments to come up with some excellent
positive prank ideas if you click on my
face you can watch Amy cross Rosenthal's
original positive pranking video and get
turned on to her amazing mission amy k
our project and then nerdfighters if you
want to do some positive framing of your
own you should and you should videotape
it and then you should upload it as a
video response to this video or Amy's
video and our pranking shall heal the
world ah oh oh it hurts when it hits the
chair I'm not gonna let you hang my
elbow could use a positive Frank
nerdfighters I hope that you guys find
the idea of positive pranking is
exciting and cool as I do Hank it was
fun hanging out with you in real life
but alas we are back to this I will see
you on the internet on Friday